[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le sais tu ce
week-end sur tv 60,18 l'émission pour
bien terminer la semaine dans les
yvelines de l'actualité mais aussi des
idées de sorties c'est parti pour le
programme de ce 29 octobre
pendant quatre jours versailles
accueille le premier championnat du
monde de judo pour les sourds et
malentendants c'est jusqu'à samedi au
gymnase mont boron 200 athlètes de 26
délégations étrangères seront présents
pour cet événement inédit en france ce
week-end c'est halloween à cette
occasion villepreux a prévu un programme
spécial maison rente et loups garous
grandeur nature concours et projection
on en parle avec laurence morel aux sons
première adjointe au maire de la commune
et puis d'un autre côté aussi nous vous
avons concocté un menu 100 % à louis nos
idées avec notamment une murder party
c'est à l'office de saint germain
boucles de seine bonjour monsieur jean
grégory je comprends pas d'habitude j'ai
l'habitude à voir avec moi bixente mes
ressentis stephen âmes avoir connu
attendait c'est bien comme ça c'est vous
que j'aille je ne s'arrache et quelques
poils de la barbe en même temps bon
c'est vous alors je suis rassuré je
pense qu'il faut revoir aussi l'acting
studio on peut travailler là ça promet
pour les branchés sur steam quel est le
menu du jour aujourd'hui vous avez parlé
des idées de sorties on va aussi parler
d' halloween à la maison avec des idées
de recettes et des films à regarder par
exemple et sera ce sera tout à l'heure
avec vous bien sûr dans ce set week-end
l actualité d'abord direction versailles
pendant quatre jours la cité royale
accueille le championnat du monde de
judo des sourds une compétition qui
réunit 26 pays au gymnase mont boron et
sur place michael et demi d'euros le
judo mondial a posé ses valises à
versailles à l'occasion des championnats
du monde de judo des sourds la
compétition créée en 2004 se dispute
tous les quatre ans cette année
l'édition versaillaise affiche un record
de participants gymnase maubon
aujourd'hui on a 26 nations différentes
qu'ils viennent du japon à l'est
jusqu'au chili à l'ouest
et principalement d'europe de dowland
centrale et d'europe et
ça fait cent soixante quinze athlètes
plus une centaine d'accompagnateurs donc
à 280 étrangers l'événement est
programmée de ce jeudi 28 octobre à ce
samedi 30 octobre il a été organisé sous
l'impulsion d'un homme d' ami antoine
champion du monde de judo des sourds en
2004 aujourd'hui ce judoka est
professeur à versailles et directeur
technique internationale pour lui la
frontière sur les tatamis entre les
valides et les sourds et mince
non d'une autre manière une autre femme
atteinte à
notre
principale difficulté se situe au niveau
de l'arbitrage et la communication etc
les athlètes on est obligé de voix de
leur signaler en les touchant que ça
commence ou que ça s'arrête mais ce sont
les seuls les seules différences par
rapport à une activité valide classique
beaucoup trop tard pour que comme une
catho officielle par un quota cas et les
plates menthe et habitera le peuple doit
être atteint par la fin du tournoi est
programmée ce samedi 30 octobre avec des
compétitions par équipes ce jour là la
seule devrait une nouvelle fois affiché
complet
dans l'actualité également le long
week-end de la toussaint qui démarre ce
vendredi soir il faudra vous armer de
patience si vous avez prévu de prendre
les transports en commun dans les trois
prochains jours et des travaux de
maintenance ont prévu conséquence un
trafic perturbé notamment sur les
yvelines sur le rer b et c pour la ligne
b au départ de saint rémy les chevreuse
par exemple pas de train entre massy
palaiseau et le guichet au nord même
chose sur le tronçon aulnay sous bois et
aéroport roissy charles de gaulle et sur
la partie business du rer c aucune
liaison ne se rassurer samedi et
dimanche entre saint quentin en yvelines
à viroflay rive gauche il faudra vous
reporter sur les trains de la ligne n
d'autres perturbations sont bien sûr à
prévoir ce week-end également en ile de
france toutes les informations sur le
site qui s'est affichée en bas de
l'écran la première semaine de là
toussaint de ces vacances de la
toussaint est sur le point de se
terminer et malgré les congés
l'actualité a été riche dans le
département ce qu'il faut retenir en 78
secondes et s'est résumée par céline
charles
[Musique]
on commence à médan ou la maison zola le
musée dédié à l affaire dreyfus a ouvert
ses portes aux visiteurs ce jeudi 28
octobre après dix années de travaux la
maison l'écrivain de j'accuse a écrit
une grande partie de son oeuvre a
retrouvé ses allures d'époque après plus
de dix ans de rénovation plusieurs
champions de natation présent lundi pour
apprendre aux jeunes de poissy a nagé
dans le cadre de l'opération nageurs et
citoyens parrainé par yannick agnel les
athlètes veulent lutter contre les
noyades 259 jeunes issus de zones
sensibles ont répondu présents dans le
cadre d'octobre rose une opération était
menée ce mercredi 27 dans le quartier du
val hibou à plaisir pour sensibiliser et
dépister gratuitement les femmes qui le
souhaitaient un même bus étaient
présentes pour dépister sans rendez vous
depuis quelques jours un supermarché
anti gaspillage et à prix bas a ouvert
ses portes à maurepas les deux jeunes
entrepreneurs à sa tête ont comme
objectif de valoriser des produits
exclus de la grande distribution et puis
enfin ça y est les 70 cadets ont
effectué leur première semaine de stage
au camp militaire de ben ces jeunes de
17 à 21 ans ont fait leurs premiers pas
dans le monde militaire au programme
apprentissage du tir du champ de peu le
ton ou encore de la marche de nuit
[Musique]
nous suivrons tout au long de l'année
c'est à cadets de la gendarmerie votre
rubrique légal checking à présent pour
vérifier ce que disent les acteurs de
l'actualité elle réformer la justice
beaucoup de candidats à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 fond cette
proposition est l'occasion pour vincent
couronne du collectif des surligneurs de
décrypter aujourd'hui l'une d'elles
regarder
pour rendre la justice plus efficace les
candidats en lice pour l'élection
présidentielle n'hésite pas à formuler
des propositions choc xavier bertrand
veut ainsi donner davantage de pouvoirs
aux procureurs en leur permettant de
prononcer des amendes pour les délits
punis au maximum de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement
cette proposition ne sort pas de nulle
part depuis de nombreuses années le
législateur à développer des procédures
d'alternative aux poursuites la
composition pénale un permettent ainsi
aux procureurs de proposer une peine à
l'auteur d'une infraction plutôt que de
le renvoyer devant un juge la
composition pénale ne s'applique qu'aux
délits punis de moins de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et suppose la
reconnaissance préalable par l'auteur de
sa culpabilité et surtout surtout quand
juge valide cette condamnation avec sa
proposition
xavier bertrand en invente donc pas une
nouvelle procédure mais le candidat à la
primaire les républicains proposent ici
de se passer systématiquement du juge
certes depuis 2019 il n'est plus
obligatoire de faire valider la
composition pénale par un juge pour les
plus petits délices à dire lorsque la
menthe prononcée est inférieure à 3000
euros et que le délit est puni de moins
de 3 ans d'emprisonnement mais en se
passant systématiquement du juge la
france prendrait le risque d'être
condamnée par la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme qui a déjà jugé que le
procureur français n'était pas une
autorité judiciaire indépendante du
gouvernement le conseil constitutionnel
pourrait faire de même ce n'est pas
étonnant cette réforme reviendrait à
donner au procureur qui est sous
l'autorité du gouvernement un pouvoir
démesuré or en démocratie pour éviter
l'arbitraire du pouvoir la justice est
rendue par la justice et une justice
indépendante
et place à présent à la partie loisirs
dans ce set week-end
avec bixente imérien sortie stéphane qui
a retiré la moustache qui a toujours son
très beau costume de six trous une coupe
des années 80 veut dire je suis quand
même un peu plus identifiable maintenant
je crois alors comment les yvelinois
vont célébrer halloween ce week-end ben
justement on est allé dans un dans les
allées d'un centre commercial plaisir
aux as et lagat tsongo a demandé
justement aux yvelinois ce qu'ils
avaient prévu
moi ça va être un mariachis des los
muertos on a une salle de restaurant on
va faire une fête on met en réaliser et
soirée chez les déguisements et tout ce
qu'il faut ça va être très simple je m
des cornes de diable s et mettre les
lentilles fantaisie quelque chose de
sympa trop pas trop quoi donc soirée
entre amis voilà j'aime déguisé en
vampire
avec la censure moi un vrai décor est
notre maison
avec trois des choses et surtout des
citrouilles et
rage est une diversion avec les enfants
on va aller
faire des blagues net en sonnant chez
les gens c'est faire peur aux petites
aux personnes âgées bon alors c'est tout
comme d'habitude c'est récupérer les
bons surtout bon on valide pas forcément
la dernière idée bon c'est très
intéressant dans les réponses très
variés et paris de votre plus beau
costume comme c'est le cas pour vous ou
bixente on pourra aller célébrer aussi
halloween du côté de la commune de ville
preuve oui en effet la commune propose
samedi et dimanche des journées 100%
halloween au programme mais pointe et
loups garous grandeur nature concours on
en parle avec laurence morel leçon
première adjointe en charge de
l'environnement du développement durable
de l'agriculture de la vie culturelle à
la commune de villepreux pourquoi
d'abord proposé cette animation quels
sont les objectifs alors comme vous le
savez villes pro est une ville très
familial donc c'est vrai que nous
souhaitions à l'occasion de cette
période de l'halloween proposés voilà
une séquence événementiel importante
propice à des moments de jeu des changes
en famille et en plus pour ce moment
fort comme pour tous les moments forts
que nous concevons actuellement nous
essayons vraiment de proposer une
programmation
riche de manière à ce qu on
puisse répondre à un public large des
familles avec des enfants d'âge
différent des gens qui veulent
faire des activités en présentiel
d'autres plutôt en distance yale donc
vraiment notre programmation
d'événements pour halloween elle est
riche et varié familiale tous les âges
en fait seront servis en est exactement
exactement avec vraiment des moments
forts et divers justement on va revenir
sur le programme la maison saint vincent
a été transformé en maison hantée pour
l'occasion que pourra-t-on y trouver et
comment se déroule l'animation
finalement alors vous l'avez dit non
plus la maison saint vincent qui n'ont
qu'une maison emblématique dans le vieux
village a été transformée grâce aux
animateurs de nos accueils de loisirs en
une vraie maison hantée assez
terrifiante et donc on propose à partir
de samedi après midi jusqu'à jusqu'en
soirée jusqu'à 22 heures et dimanche de
14h à 18h par créneau en fait il ya
vraiment des groupes restreints puisque
évidemment toute cette offre
évènementielle on dit ça en rigolant
mais il faut aussi tenir compte des
contraintes sanitaires donc c'est par
groupes de quinze ou vingt fois tout est
expliqué sur le site de la mairie on
demande à tous les enfants de plus de 12
ans d'avoir un passani terre de garder
le masque toute la durée du du jeu enfin
voilà tout ce fait voilà pour donner des
frissons mais aussi dans la sécurité pat
fry centièmes réservation obligatoire
précise juste les horaires samedi 14h
22h et dimanche de 14 heures à 18 heures
voilà ça c'est pour la maison hantée
après on a aussi un autre moment fort de
la science à dimanche un jeu grandeur
nature grégory je vous laisse faire le
pitch oui effectivement dans le vieux
village on raconte il ya très longtemps
lors de certaines nuits des loups garous
rôdait dans les ruelles et s'attaquer
aux villageois terrifiés cette vieille
légende oublié de tous a refait surface
étrangement il ya quelques jours des
criées puissant de loups ont été
entendus non loin du parc de la cave et
elle a peur a refait surface dans les
chaumières pas de doute les loups garous
sont de retour donc c'est une partie de
loup garou jean proposé dans le pas de
la cave et quel est le cas les le
principe alors c'est un jeu de rôle pour
ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas le loup
garou c'est un jeu de cartes qui et qui
donne lieu à un jeu de rôle ce qui est
important dans le cadre de ce que nous
proposons à villepreux c'est qu'on a
vraiment voulu proposer des sessions de
jeu différenciée selon les âges des
enfants parce que comme c'est un jeu de
rôle qui repose à la fois sûr
l'habilité physique là comment dire le
la réactivité quant aux réponses parce
qu'il ya des moments de dialogue et tout
ça ça n'aurait pas eu beaucoup de sens
de faire jouer des enfants de huit ans
contre d'autres qui en avait 18 donc il
ya différentes séquences encore une fois
tout ça et est expliqué sur le site
internet selon les âges des enfants
moins de 12 ans 12 16 et plus de sel
sachant que la séance de plus de 16 elle
commence à 22 heures donc à la c c'est
vraiment très halloween possession nous
dimanche 18h pour les bonnes raisons 20
heures pour les plus de 12 ans
d'ancienneté et 22 heures pour les plus
de 16 ans comme pour moi exactement je
serai un peu moins peur peut-être que
les loups garous mai et la commune lance
aussi deux concours à l'occasion
d'halloween un auquel je pourrais
peut-être participer déguisements et de
décorations
d'art de décoration de maison et de
balcons aussi je commence alors il ya
deux concours en effet donc les concours
de maisons les maisons basses encore une
fois ci s'est expliqué sur le site
internet il faut s'inscrire et en fait
nous avons un jury qui circulent entre
aujourd'hui demain pour voile à noter
les différentes maisons gagnante et le
deuxième concours sont un concours comme
vous le disiez de déguisements donc
pareil on s'inscrit les inscriptions
c'est de 9h à minuit dimanche on envoie
les photos sachant que ça on peut
commencer avec des photos d'un un membre
de la famille à partir de quelques mois
jusqu'à plus de cent ans on peut
participer individuellement peut
participer en groupe d'amis ou en
famille voilà le but c'est vraiment de
de faire une petite mise en scène qui
soit qu'ils soient sympathiques je
précise juste une chose que pour ces
deux concours vraiment la ville à
veiller à proposer aussi des des lots
gagnants de belle facture on a des beaux
jeux de société comme ça on reste dans
le moment d'échangés de plaisir en
famille puis ça nous permet en plus de
faire un petit clin d'oeil à notre
séquence prochaine puisque après au mois
de novembre le 20 novembre on a le
festival du jeu à villepreux et juste
une dernière chose parce que je disais
qu'on avait voulu cibler un peu tous les
profils de famille on a aussi demain une
séquence plutôt destiné à des jeunes
enfants puisque avec le réseau des
médiathèques de saint quentin à 11h dans
notre médiathèque nautilus on a une
séance cinéma vraiment destiné aux tout
petits avec des petits courts métrages
se sentir mais voilà mais voilà on va
dire n'en dit pas plus voilà pas avec
des frissons quand on va dire à la
taille des tout-petits passé trois ans
et c'est aussi sur réservation merci
laurent mangel besson d'être venu en ami
et détailler ce programme première
adjointe en charge de l'environnement du
développement durable de l'agriculture
et de la vie culturelle à villepreux et
est ce que vous serez déguisez-vous ce
week-end mais absolument et je viendrai
peut-être même avec des citrouilles de
villepreux parce que vous savez que
ville prête une ville très agricole et
on a des citrouilles de villepreux d'où
l'hommage de bixente
c'est d'avoir été avec nous alors on
poursuit notre tour d'horizon à
saint-germain-en-laye bixente l'office
de tourisme organise ce samedi 30
octobre une murder party et donc c'est
une enquête interactive c'est ça c'est
ça exactement donc pour halloween
l'office de tourisme saint germain
boucles de seine organise la majeure
partie pour passer un moment frissons en
famille une scène de crime un mort et un
suspect a recherché voilà comment débute
la murder party à la villa eugénie
dezauzier locaux de l'office de tourisme
de saint germain en laye une enquête
palpitante
à découvrir en famille la volonté
d'organiser des maraudeurs parti à
l'aîné en fait en la première qu'on a
fait elle est en 2018
on aime
venez devenir office de tourisme
intercommunal on venait d'emménager dans
des nouveaux locaux et c'était
l'occasion de vous surfez un peu sur
cette vague d murder d'être là de
pouvoir proposer bah finalement une
une activité interactive qui est adapté
aussi bien aux adultes qu'aux enfants
cette soirée interactive spécial
halloween s'organise sur deux étages le
public part à la recherche d'énigmes et
d' indices pour retrouver là où le
coupable une sorte de cluedo grandeur
nature le principe c'est qu'un meurtre a
été commis en 1908 au sein de la demeure
des des voiliers qui laquelle l'office
du tourisme en tête et il leur ancienne
demeure et il le public doit se mettre
dans la peau d'un d'enquêtrice et
d'enquêteur et pouvoir résoudre cette
affaire en une la murder party est
organisée samedi 30 octobre et compte
trois créneaux le premier est à 17
heures à peu près où on a peut-être
avancer à 16h45 a pris en à un vers 18
heures et le dernier vers 19h30 le but
cela c'est une spéciale halloween donc
c'était quand même d'avoir un peu
l'effet nocturne de nuit réservation
obligatoire le public est invité à se
déguiser pour l'événement sur saint
germain en laye les commerçants
proposent également une chasse au trésor
samedi 30 octobre après midi
voilà quelques idées pour sortir à
bixente mais on peut aussi fêter
halloween chez soi recevoir pourquoi pas
aussi à des amis pour une soirée
déguisée élaborer des plats insolite
bixente vous nous avez concocté quelque
chose oui les doigts de sorcières de
quoi effrayer vos invités c'est tout
simple des petits sablés à la confiture
pour en faire 15 comme moi il vous
suffit d'avoir 125 g de farine 62 g et
demi de maïzena 62 g et demi de sucre
125 g de beurre de la confiture ou de la
gelée de framboise ou toutes autres
fruits rouges d'ailleurs et enfin des
petites amandes effilées à part les
amendes j'avais tout chez moi par
exemple donc rien de très compliqué en
fait à obtenir moi je suis un homme
pressé combien de temps pour cette
recette je ne pouvais compter 30 à 40
minutes ont comme ça oui voilà
exactement c'est rapide on commence tout
simplement par mélanger le beurre
ramolli et le sucre puis on ajoute la
farine et la maïzena attention à bien
travailler le tout il faut que ce soit
homogène ensuite une fois que ça a été
fait
pour une fois qu'on fait une belle boule
on forme des petits doigts il faut
effilée l'extrémité afin qu'ils aient
l'air de vrais doit de sorcières en un
peu plus faim parce que ça gonflera au
four vous le verrez une fois que c'est
fait c'est là que votre âme d'artiste
peut s'exprimer avec le dos d'un couteau
faire des traits pour délimiter les
phalanges et planter une petite amende
au bout en guise d'ongles nous on a fait
un petit test on a fait une rangée avec
un peu de sens donc de la confiture en
dessous de longues et l'autre sans rien
à vous de voir ce que vous trouvez plus
réaliste on finit par cuire à 180 degrés
au four pendant dix minutes et à la
sortie on laisse refroidir en 30 dans la
confiture et la sphère est plié allez
pour les belles images que l'on voit de
justin brazy avec vous qui vous êtes
prêté à cette recette ça c'est pour la
partie théorie mais ce que vous avez des
petites astuces pour une recette 100 %
réussi oui enfin c'est dans les recettes
de cuisine ils nous disent pas ce qui
pourrait mal se passer avec ce que nous
on l'a testé il ya eu deux petits couacs
d'autres optique ois que c'est toujours
parfait quand ça sort du four dans les
recettes mais voilà trois petits
conseils pour vous numéro un comme je le
disais les doigts ça gonfle au four les
nôtres il était très réaliste en
rentrant en sortant ça ressemblait
plutôt à des doigts dogues en fait au
final 2e astuces pour les plus pressés
justement comme vous grégory plutôt que
de faire les doigts un par un vous
pouvez tout simplement faire une longue
file en fait un long tronçon avec la
pâte et couper au couteau et enfin
dernière chose ça paraît logique mais il
faut un plateau pour cuire et non une
grille puisque sinon sa faune et sa
tombe on a dû s'y reprendre nous par
exemple ça paraît logique comme je
l'aimé il vaut mieux préciser et
dernière petite chose pour plus de
réalisme les amendes un peu ébréché en
guise donc ça rend beaucoup plus stylé
en fait au final est donc vous êtes venu
avec votre assiette et vaudois de
sorcière exactement
il en manque deux trois il y en avait 15
qui ont été mangés en rédaction
leicester voilà pour goûter ça a été
apprécié oui plutôt oui la recette a été
plutôt apprécié la merci du cente pour
cette recette est justement une fois la
recette effectuer les temps de
s'installer confortablement sur son
canapé le petit plaide le petit chocolat
chaud aussi pour regarder un bon film
d'halloween et vous avez aussi quelques
idées cessation ici vous êtes en panne
d'inspiration voici un petit top 3 des
films à découvrir qui vous mettront dans
l'ambiance
[Musique]
c'était en 1978 il y à
5937 jours chez des failles son passé
chargé d'horreur lui a valu à tout autre
surnom la capitale du meurtre aux états
unis ce qui nous arrive
[Musique]
hier mois
et
[Musique]
moi je suis un grand fan des douars aux
mains d'argent c'est un film moi qui m'a
beaucoup ému il ya aussi d'autres tim
burton qui une qu'on peut regarder voilà
on va pas tous les citer mais les noces
funèbres notamment il ya un gros
programme avec steam avec la sica a
retrouvé à redécouvrir ou à découvrir
chez soi mais aussi halloween on peut
aller voir des films cinéma parce que
c'est le moment où les réalisateurs les
productions sorte justement des films
dédiés halloween exactement et pour les
plus courageux halloween kills le nouvel
opus de la célèbre saga d'horreur c'est
la suite d'halloween sortie en 2018 on
reprend donc où on nous avait laissé le
célèbre tueur en série michael myers est
laissée aux prises des flammes par
laurie strode celle qu'il avait voulu
assassiner avec sa famille vous l'aurez
deviné il parvient à se libérer bien sûr
sinon il n'y a pas de scénario il veut
se venger et reprendre son petit rituel
de meurtre reste à savoir s'il réussira
ou non à éliminer tous les habitants de
la ville d'aden fils mais vous bixente
peut-être une âme sensible vous irait
plutôt voir la famille addams oui
exactement c'est une suite aussi celle
du dessin animé sorti en 2019 notre
petite troupe de morts-vivants part en
retraite entre les etats-unis et le
canada afin de ressouder leurs liens
familiaux de prime abord c'est une
aventure joyeuse en camping car mais
qu'est-ce qui pourrait mal tourner
réponse dans nos salles voilà pour ses
idées de sortie dans les salles voilà
pour ses idées aussi autour d'halloween
mais vous le savez le 7-8 week-end on
vous donne aussi des idées pour le
week-end qui va arriver celui des 6 et 7
novembre et donc des idées mais qui
reste quand même tout de même dans
l'ambiance d'halloween on n'est pas loin
la première en tout cas c'est vrai
puisque c'est une visite de cimetières
bon normalement pas de risque que
quelqu'un soit déguisé en squelette ou
morts vivants et bien nous effrayer
pendant mais tout de même c'est le
cimeterre duhamel de mantes-la-jolie qui
ouvre ses portes samedi 6 novembre pour
une visite et une découverte des
sépultures et leur histoire et de
l'histoire il y en a puisque le
cimetière existe depuis le 11e siècle
avec enterré notamment alphonse durant
où le peintre albert d'agneau donc ses
25 personnes maximum qui seront conviés
à cette visite et le tarif est de 8
euros 70 pour les adultes et 4 40 pour
les tarifs réduits une autre activité
insolite du chien de traîneau mais à
plaisir oui c'est assez exceptionnel
puisque des courses de chiens de
traîneaux sont organisées samedi ce
dimanche 7 novembre deux façons d'y
participer soit en tant que müller c'est
le nom des guides des meneurs de chiens
de traîneaux voilà si vous saviez pas
c'est les moucheurs 75 attelages sont
disponibles soit en tant que spectateur
pour venir apprécier la vitesse des
caennais puisqu'ils peuvent courir
jusqu'à 40 km heure au niveau des
traîneaux s'est pas vraiment des
traîneaux puisque vous vous doutez qu'il
ne neigera probablement pas donc ça va
tirer des vélos des trottinettes ou des
cartes merci bixente pour toutes ces
idées on le rappelle ce week-end c'est
halloween merci de nous avoir concocté
justement ce programme est ce que il ya
eu l'idée vous qui vous intéressent la
danse que vous nous avez donné moi je
vais suivre l'avis du micro trottoir je
vais faire une petite fête entre amis
avec mes petits doigts de sorcière
justement que j'aurais peut-être fait
pour l'occasion et on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
émission exactement comme milieu droit
en tenue peut-être un peu plus
classiquement de l'efficacite moi je
vais quand même retirer le masque pour
vous saluer merci d'avoir été avec nous
j'espère que ce programme quasiment 100%
lwin vous a intéressé lundi ne manquez
pas sur tes les 78 le retour du 7-8
journal et d'ici là passez un excellent
week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]